and welcome back to our set at the
Tucson Festival and books of books in
this beautiful southwestern desert town
where I hate to tell you folks at 77
degrees those of you sitting in colder
climes David Cay Johnston is our guest
he's been a fixture on c-span over the
years with his Pulitzer Prize winning
reporting as an investigative journalist
and especially focusing on financial
issues and tax reporting so we've just
heard your panel session earlier today
another panel session spent much of the
time suggesting that this is a
decades-long change in American society
that mr. Trump is a symbol of you got
into that at the end here and it sounded
more like you think he's a phenomenon no
no in fact at the end of my current book
it's even worse than you think I point
out that Donald Trump is a symptom the
disease is that we are allowing our
democracy to atrophy voter participation
rates a hundred million people could
have voted in the 2016 elections and did
not people not paying attention and
there's a philosophy that I follow in
the book and that my nonprofit News
Service DC report singular DC report org
follows it's our government we own it we
should act like owners when you
outsource your government to other
people it's the people to make money off
governments who start running the
government for you and the other ones
who pick your pockets I did a trilogy of
books about that the c-span had me on
four perfectly legal free lunch and the
fine print about all these rules and
laws nobody knew about till I wrote
about them on how Washington and the
state capitals pick your pockets because
people are not paying enough attention
to the duties of citizenship it's our
government we own it act like owners
last question because their callers are
all stacked up for you this is a complex
society with a lot of personality driven
entertainment and media people are busy
with their lives how do how do you think
we get to a society where people pay
attention and act like owners well I
think we have to start with our
education system which was created in
the late 19th century and was designed
to produce uncritical drones to
work in industrial America we're now
moving into a dirty different economy
where we need critical thinking skills
and we need to update our education
system that's long term in the short
term people need to recognize that your
income your safety your children's
welfare are tied up with government
policies and if you care about yourself
and your family and your neighbors then
you need to say I've got to put some
time into really learning what's going
on here
let's listen to Ellen in Tarzana
California Ellen you are on for mr.
Johnston go ahead please yes I have an
observation during the Book Festival but
the reason a lot of these stories were
not getting out is that all the major
networks are very litigious now and they
are not going to run a story that they
think they're going to get sued over
particularly PBS they don't have the
budget for it and I think this is one
reason why reporters I'm surprised that
there are many good reporters as are
because they can investigate till the
cows come home and produce very good
stories only a small amount or none will
get on the major network once they
passed the news director who has
probably been advised by the political I
mean by the legal department and I think
this is tad definitely an effect on what
gets out to the particularly after dan
Rather and CBS had to pay for that story
I think there's been a downward trend
Thank You Ellen your panel touched on
that a bit we did well first of all PBS
there is a real problem because of
congressional funding and it has cowed
them when they interviewed me they said
anything I said about Trump and
criminals in the Mafia they were gonna
not foot on the air and they did it the
network's I think are somewhat different
story the coverage since the since
Donald Trump took the Oval Office has
been I think in many ways very good and
very aggressive what we're not seeing
enough coverage of is of the government
what is happening to our government
that's always a tough deal for TV
because of the
nature of how television works Donald
Trump certainly has tried to intimidate
people he's been threatened to sue me
for 29 years you know if he thinks what
I'm saying about him isn't true I invite
him to sue me
but I don't see the problem Ellen does
so much of censorship because of
litigation I see it because of enormous
pushback from people who see Donald
Trump as a demagogue a demagogue but a
demagogue and they don't want to hear
anything critical about him
and at the end of the day commercial TV
is about advertising next calls from
John and here in Tucson John welcome to
the conversation go ahead thank you why
no one mentions the fact that Eric
Prince is commander of night two multi
that's the Knights of Malta in America
thank you okay well you're a right to
belong to any organization you want in
this country I mean our Constitution
protects your right of assembly and
implied in that is of association but I
think you're going to hear more about
mr. Prince in the near future because
he's becoming more relevant to the
Moller investigation would you also
explain the cabinet connection with Eric
Prince well Eric Prince is the younger
brother of Betsy DeVos the education
secretary who became secretary only
because Mike Pence cast the deciding
vote and I think that's the only time
we've ever had to have a vice president
cast the deciding vote on confirmation
of a candidate it's the lowest vote
count anybody's gotten in our history
next up is Zachary Long Beach California
Zachary you're on for David Cay Johnston
and Tucson thank you Oh first of all and
she said early that's just important
panel about the questions of since the
media
like Eddie just those and think such
pregnant Wow filibuster
do you think the journalist or in before
because how big about them right thank
you
well Susan I couldn't pick out Zachary's
question because we're having technical
difficulties yeah
it's question was about journalism and
the quality of reporting well the
reporting during the campaign I think
was just in defensively god-awful and
I've spoken out about it in a number of
forums there was a failure to scrub the
candidate who's now president I think
the coverage since January twentieth of
2017 of the White House has been
absolutely superb some of the best I've
seen in my lifetime the coverage of
what's happening in our government which
is the focus of my book and of DC report
still very very lacking and I'll give
you a simple example of that
DC report we put up a story yesterday
that the Trump administration has once
again delayed a beryllium rule to
American workers die every week because
we don't have this beryllium rule and
they keep delaying it it's been delayed
now since March of last year and nobody
else is recording this certainly none of
the mainstream news organizations are
reporting it so the coverage of the
government not so good the coverage of
the White House fantastic was there ever
a point in which cover a coverage of
government was good it's been better in
the past but one of the reasons Brian
has created c-span was exactly that we
were talking enough about our government
and too much about politics but we used
to have yes more coverage there was a
time when the Housing and Urban
Development Department actually had a
reporter covering it was a time when the
IRS had a reporter covering it for the
New York Times me and now State and the
Defense Department National Intelligence
are sort of the only agencies that
really have reporters there hasn't been
a beat reporter at the Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission in years even
though its actions affect your
pocketbook every single month
next up is Bob in Overland Park Kansas
Bob you are on welcome and the parcel
and Bob I'm so sorry I'm gonna interrupt
you and as you could see a david johnson
and i are having difficulty with getting
the connection here and i apologize for
that we're told by the producer he
wanted to know about the debates so go
back to the a campaign and the way those
debates were structured and how they
ended up in affecting the process i'm
sorry we're having the technical
difficulties i think we need to
completely blow up the way we do the
debates we have television personalities
asking the questions i would rather see
the two candidates duke it out with one
another and i'd like to see serious
print journalists or online journalists
asking questions and i'll give you two
examples if if i had been one of the
people questioning donald trump I would
have said Donald you've been talking
about running for president since 1985
presumably you have read and even
studied the Job Description with
specificity where is it written down and
what are the duties powers and limits of
the presidency Donald could not have
answered that question I'm absolutely
certain of it just as in the 1984
election I would have asked Mondale and
Reagan about family value
and asked them to talk about the last
time they had seen their grandchildren
Mondale was well known for going home
from the Capitol to have dinner with his
children at night Ronald Reagan at that
point had never met his grandchildren
and I think that would have been very
revealing about the idea of family
values and we need to have much better
questions ask them we got a bunch of
softball questions lobbed at candidates
and that's just not the way to run
debates okay we're going to try another
one keep your fingers crossed
in Ormond Beach California Ron go ahead
please hi I was listening to a panel
about a month after Trump was elected
the panel consisted of John you and he
were talking about how truck knew
everything about a building you know the
particulars now Trump actually know
about the particulars of constructing a
building or that he's just slap his name
up on the building well Ron that's a
real good question first of all people
should know who john yoo is he's a law
professor I believe at Boalt Hall at the
University of California who famously
wrote memos supporting some of the I
would regard as worst policies of the
Bush administration regarding detainees
in the war on terror
Donald is appallingly ignorant I once at
lunch was going over one of his business
deals with him and I could see him
getting more and more and more
apprehensive and suddenly goes how do
you know that and I said well because
you put all of this in the public record
and I studied it and it was very clear
that I knew his business deal better
than he did and Donald knows how to cut
corners and save money but he has no
deep knowledge literally on anything and
there's plenty of his testimony under
oath things he's written in interviews
he's given that document things and I'll
my favorite example for you is Donald I
quote in my book it's even worse than
you think as saying in shorthand I'm the
world's greatest expert of all time
on taxes all time nobody knows more
about taxes than Donald Trump Donald
under oath was asked what do you know
about accounting and he said I don't
anything about accounting well that
would be the equivalent of me and I am a
well known tax expert saying I am the
world's greatest airplane designer
what's a wing I wanted to talk to you
about writing of books and swear at the
Book Festival and your book is about a
moving target every day there is another
story to cover another aspect of the
story and a book is a snapshot in time
so how does a book work for you as a
journalist well this was this book in
particular was a real serious problem it
covers the first 250 days and you know I
wish it could have covered the first 365
days so what I did was set out to say
what are the things that we know that we
can establish and that you don't know
that is if I just tell you what's in the
news you're not going to want to read
the book and I'm not doing anything for
you and my job as the reporter is to
particularly as investigative reporters
to tell you things you would not know
but for my work so I focused on stuff
that either was not in the news at all
or was glancingly in the news to tell
you these stories of what's going on
inside our government read about a
fellow who was a high level and of chair
interior official and executive today he
processes oil royalty checks as he won't
quit I tell about a woman named if I
recall correctly Betsy Outlander I'm
sure I'm bouncing her name at EPA who
she and her team were told to prepare
detailed reports on every weakness in
the Clean Water Act if they were to try
and enforce it and they turned all this
over and of course it is basically now a
guide to how to avoid having the federal
government enforce the Clean Water Act
that Richard Nixon signed against you
and so to walk through what's going on
inside our government but I also had to
look at the fact that there's a set
deadline and it's got to be discreet and
clear to people and it has to be useful
even as events change in the future it's
not an easy trick but that we came out
first at number 2 on the New York Times
bestseller list
and then ran out of books suggested I
did a reasonably good job at it next up
is Wendy here in Tucson hi Wendy
welcome hi so I just have a really quick
question I'm one that believes that the
president is more of a figurehead he
basically is to look at and I mean he
does have seems to do with the
government don't get me wrong but it's
our our Congress our senators
they're the ones that actually push
everything through and am I wrong in
thinking that we need to actually clean
that up and maybe have limits on the
time they're spending there instead of
saying you know I mean don't get me
wrong Trump is an embarrassment but
don't we have to clean up other parts
before we can get clean that really need
to be cleaned well when do you let me
break that into two pieces okay and
first let me deal with this particular
president Donald Trump is not actively
engaged in many many things that are
going on what happened is that team
Trump the people he brought with him
have put into our government what I call
political termites and just like
termites will eat away at the walls and
the flooring in your house if you're not
aware of them until one day you put your
foot through the floor in the kitchen
and discover you have a huge bill that's
come due Trump has put people whose
names in many cases have never been in
the news and who I write about in my
book who are busily making the
government ineffective and remember that
Steve bannon's calls himself a Leninist
meaning he believes that the existing
order should be destroyed completely and
replaced said that this administration
would deconstruct the administrative
state which is this complex way of
saying we're gonna make the government
ineffective so there's a real problem
there but it's not Trump directing these
things it's the people who came with him
on the larger issue yes the framers of
our Constitution intended that the
executive was there to carry out the
assignments essentially given by
Congress now max boo
a noted conservative Republican who's
here at this conference said a couple of
weeks ago that he believes as a former
Republican he resigned over Trump that
every Republican member of Congress who
hasn't stood up to Trump needs to be
voted out of office
and I certainly think we would we need a
new Congress we need a Congress that
will in fact react to and will fulfill
its constitutional duties under our
system of checks and balances with
regard to this president
I don't limit that to Republicans I'm a
registered Republican but I do think
that there's a real problem with our
reelecting people I don't like term
limits I think that people who are doing
their job ought to stay in their job if
they're doing it well but voters need to
stop this practice of saying well I
really hate what Congress is doing but I
like my Congress person you need to be
as skeptical and as hard Flynn died
about your own member of Congress and
your own senators as you are the
institution and a wholesale change I
think be a very good thing right now we
have 30 seconds till we're finished here
and it's gonna get loud again but do you
think you're surprised a lot of people
with your party registration just now
probably I registered as a Republican
because where I live the only
interesting elections primaries of the
Republicans and after all you know the
Democrats you would never get the chance
to vote for a presidential candidate who
thinks that cinnamon buns cure diabetes
most most journalists did not announce
their party registered well I agree but
I was asked one day on television by Lou
Dobbs and he was at CNN what my party
registration was and I said it and a
couple of editors of the New York Times
write worst and we're unhappy about it
not because of the registration but
there was their attitude and mine is you
know you ask a question I'll give you an
honest answer the book is called it's
even worse than you think what the Trump
administration is doing to America David
Cay Johnston our guest here at the
Tucson Festival of Books thank you for
being with us and thank you we're gonna
take you now back to the Gallagher
theater here at the University of
Arizona and we're gonna be here until
7:30 eastern time 5:30 if you're
watching here in the mountain time zones
with lots more from the Tucson Book
Festival but coming up next Scott Kelly
the astronaut and his book endurance and
after that he'll be on our set
to take your calls about his life in
America's space program
now to the Gallacher theater